[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney number one
bestselling author a couple times over
and host of the Dr John deloney show
Ramsey personal
is my co-host today Merry Christmas
America we're glad you're here open
phones at
5225 that's
5225 Madison is with us to start off
this hour in Atlanta Georgia hi Madison
welcome to the
show hi Dave hi John um thank you so
much for taking my call sure what's up
um so I'm in a predicament um that I've
actually made myself um I got married uh
second marriage for both of us um uh not
quite six years ago um and at that time
um I had been through a pretty bad
divorce and had a pretty uh uh traumatic
first marriage so definitely was healing
from that and met this wonderful man so
nice to me and kind to me and um I just
felt head over heels and love with him
um I knew he was broke I knew he didn't
have any money and that that just didn't
matter to me he was just so nice to me
and I loved being treated nice so um we
got married um I did have him sign a
prenup because I was uh expecting to
inherit a large amount of money from my
parents estate at some point I hadn't at
that time but um I knew that that would
be in the future and uh so he did sign a
prenuptual agreement and didn't have any
problems with that um however I started
our relationship with just paying all
the time I I paid for everything we'd go
out for dinner I would pay um I already
had a place where I lived that I paid
for and uh you know etc etc so I I
understand how I've kind of set a
pattern um and at the time it didn't
bother me and you know I might want I
also want to add this man's Christian
man he knows the word of God um you know
we really I really have put this in
God's hands and asked for his help um
but um I just I just can't figure out
where why there's just there's no Spirit
of generosity with with him he just I've
brought up several times you know can
you please pitch in just kick in I don't
expect half and half I have plenty of
money I don't I don't need his money
it's just on principle just I just need
to know that I'm not just the only one
that's pouring us I feel like I'm I'm
the bread winner so he doesn't earn an
income he he did we are both retired now
um he does not have any retirement how
old are you guys I'm 60 he's 64 okay um
he took uh he took social security early
he was working at that time and then
um when you stay when you start taking
social security you you're you can only
work so many hours you can only make so
much money um so that knocked his out
you know availability down to where he
really couldn't work very much but since
then we've both retired and relocated
and um so what do you feel like the core
question
is um I I think I'm just trying to
figure out if um if I'm being taken
advantage of is this just something
where I'm I'm being you know I've
brought something up several times and I
just nothing changes nothing it just
stays the same
and I don't know if I what I guess what
my next step should be as far as hold on
this this is this isn't a money issue
this is a respect issue you don't
respect the man that you're married
to because like I I bring
home I I I bring home a quote unquote
income to the house but my wife my God
Almighty if if she disappeared the house
would go away so I don't look at her and
say wow you're not contributing to this
thing and I'm paying for dinner all the
time because my money is our
money right and and the home that she
keeps and runs and her small business
like that's ours too but there's a
mutual respect
there so this doesn't have to do with
money and you mentioned
earlier you don't want a thing you don't
want your marriage to be where you're
paying for everything it is that is the
world you set up so yeah the only thing
you can do from this point forward is to
create something new but this is a
respect issue this isn't a I just need
him to pitch in issue have you been very
clear about what you need or has it been
a ah you know like man I sure am paying
for a lot and he might be thinking well
it's our money have you been very clear
with him I'm I'm not no I'm I'm very
afraid of Confrontation I get very
nervous about uh talking about something
like this about then you end up in
resentment land because you spend a ton
of time having a AR conversations in
your head don't you yes oh I do that's
cruel and unfair to him and doubt yeah
yes so if you're going to be mad on your
brain too yeah if if if if you're going
to be mad at him he at
least deserves to know what he could do
give him a path back to relationship
because right now he married somebody
with a lot of money and he might think
he's fulfilling his duties as your
husband by being the funloving guy that
just whatever whatever partridge in a
parat Tre he needs to know you don't
respect him
yeah I do I do love them and I don't
want uh I don't want anything to end I
what does he need to do to be a person
that you would respect because he
doesn't need to work you guys are
retired no it's not a work it's not a
work ethic thing what is it that he's
supposed to do that makes him valid in
your
mind I think just pitching in say I
don't know a ,000 a month something
something so from what where's he got
money he has Social Security money and
he gets other money from so you guys
don't have your finances combined at
all um we do have a joint checking
account but he's never put any money in
it so no I mean but does he have an
Avenue to do
that he could yeah he he could he could
put money in there yeah because he's on
the he's on the account but if he's
looking at your vast amount of money in
that account and he at his ply his ply
um government
check yeah see what I'm saying like he
needs to know and I again I I think he's
going to put $1,000 doar in that account
and that's not what the issue is going
to
be yeah if he started depositing $1,000
a month in that account you'd be right
back here in six
months I don't know if I would be I
don't it's really it's to me it's like
you just said it's not about money it's
more about um respect and I think
because this has gone on for so long and
you know I've allowed it to go on so
long and this pattern's been set now um
I want to rewrite the rules I guess well
since y'all are married y'all get to
rewrite them together right and so I
think it's a matter of sitting down and
having a conversation and say hey we've
been married for a few years um I need
you to do this to have me have positive
respectful feelings towards you
and what can I do for you so that you
can have positive respectful feelings
towards me let's put all of it on the
table M let's give each other a chance
for Success yeah 100% of what you don't
say he can't hear right
yeah I've been married 43 years I'm
still working on that Dave I am too man
I am
too the things that are in Sharon's head
that I have never heard are amazing but
you're in trouble for them I'm always in
trou you better fix them what's wrong
nothing this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
buget
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Dr John
delone Ramsey personality is my co-host
today we appreciate you you guys hanging
out Merry Christmas to you hey if you
like what you hear around here we could
use your help please help us subscribe
click the Subscribe button click the
share button or share a link or tell
somebody where you're listening or
watching or wherever it is you're
youtubing or tbing or whatever it is
you're doing uh you know Spotify right
Apple podcast whatever it is maybe
you're listening on radio station out
there thank you just share and leave us
a festar review please we'd appreciate
it very much Merry Christmas to you
Shay is whether Shay is in Daytona hi
Shay Merry
Christmas hi Merry
Christmas good how can we
help hi um so just to cut right to The
Taste I just took out my first student
loan ever um super nerve-wracking it's
for my masters in social work and it's
about 45,000 that's without the interest
so I'm just trying and figure out what's
a great path to start on that like how
to tackle it super fast because I don't
want to be with debt for like 10
years you just took out your first loan
for a semester or you just finished a
degree program and you have $45,000 in
the
whole no so it's I it's six it's like
6,000 a semester um but they just gave
it all to me at once so it's 40 Grand 45
Grand is what they gave me at once who's
they I've never heard of that
ever it's financial aid FASA FASA so
they just cut you a check and deposit it
for
$45,000 well not into my bank it goes
directly to my school and then they
start paying it that way so it's already
given to my school and my school just
takes it out each okay so you're
starting your Masters and you just
Finance the whole thing well I I here
Dave I bet what's happened is I bet they
have you've been approved for the entire
program I bet they don't have a check
for for I bet your University doesn't
have a check for $45,000 cuz they
wouldn't prepay like that cuz you could
quit you can drop out it could be a
whole thing but my guess is you approved
for the program and the school gave you
a letter that said you've qualified for
$45,000 in federal aid and every
semester you're going to have to reup
and reup and reup and
reup okay that's my guess as to what
happened I've I've never heard of the
Govern so you're you're just starting
your
Masters yes you're spending $445,000 to
get a master's in social work to make
what kind of
money not enough it's about 90 grand
which would be Sal or yeah the salary
for it there's no way you'll make 90
grand that's the that is the um salary
in Florida for it where right now I work
at a hospital and this a starting social
worker with a lmsw makes $990,000
well not starting out no but I've been
doing social work and case management
and all that stuff for years so with the
experience and once I get it they're
going I'm already making 50 right now so
they're bumping it up wow I've that's
that's extraordinary I'm good for them
because that's that's a that's a field
that needs more people that drastically
is is usually underpaid I would I as a
as a guy who's I've taught graduate
school and mental health programs I've
lived this world what I would plead to
you is to you make $50,000 a year I
would cut back for the next three years
and cash flow this program please please
please don't chain yourself to the
federal government and then try to go
into a serving
profession it's a recipe for Burnout and
you're gonna it's just going to melt you
from the inside out please don't do
this yeah yeah that was one of my big
fears it's just like I I just definitely
don't want it lingering for so long too
and when it comes to money I bad anxiety
over it the way the way it doesn't
linger is don't take it don't take it
don't take the chat pay cash for your
degree is what John's saying $6,000 a
semester go pay it outright for the
three semesters plus your 3,000 hours
whatever you your hospital not got any
Financial uh matching for
Education not no because I'm not a nurse
they only have it for nurses
okay and what enticed me to it was
because they said at first that they
would and then when I got here they said
oh sorry no it's just for nurses yeah
I'd find another place to work too while
you're at it yeah I'm serious 100%
serious if they're going to if they're
going to lure you in and then they're
going to bait and switch you that's just
a that's a company without Integrity I
wouldn't work for
him gotcha and I know this is a radical
shift but I would go to the school and
say hey I need my semester by semester
cost and they're probably going to tell
you well it depends if you take six or
nine hours whatever and say what is what
is a full-time and what is a part-time
student going to cost and then you make
$50,000 a year until you find another
job where you'll make 60 I want you to
cash flow so what we're trying to tell
you is that uneasy feeling inside of you
when you called is real it's right and
it's telling you don't do this and we're
telling you it's right don't do it the
best way to get this degree is pay cash
for it and um you know look for someone
maybe another maybe another employer
that pays 90 when you're out but also uh
will help with the education like this
one promised but it's was riged on uh
and so let's do a couple things here
that are pretty radical but if you kind
of just you you sound pretty chill and
if you kind of just allow all this to
happen to you it's going to step on your
face don't allow this to happen you need
to stand up Square your shoulders and
head straight into this with your teeth
you know with with a warrior yell girl I
mean you need to get after it John's in
Jackson Mississippi hey John welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey Dave how's it going
better than I deserve what's up uh I
have a question about getting a SBA loan
to purchase a business what's your
thoughts on that is is never never never
under any
circumstances okay it's a disaster why
would you buy a why would you buy a
business a small
business um well so I travel 10 months
out of the year and my wife stays at
home with kids and it's a taxing life
yeah and we're trying to find a happy
medium for everybody and we stumble what
we think is a good opportunity per se
and we just uh what is the industry that
the business you're looking at is in U
making
signs okay and how much is the purchase
uh approximately 1.2 million dollars yes
sir for a signed
franchise it's not a franchise it's a
person that started the
business and he's looking to retire okay
all right um let me give you a different
way to skin this cat maybe okay but um
let me uh 80% of small businesses fail
in the first five years okay the number
one cause of small business failure when
we survey them and we work with 10,000
small businesses in Entre leadership
right now is what's called cash flow
problems cash flow problems is a uh a
phrase that means a lot of things but it
primarily means two things I can't pay
my debt payments M and I didn't pay my
taxes on time and I get screwed by the
federal government
and um so you're going to have a million
two floating around around your neck
trying to drag you down while you're
trying to run a business that this guy's
already been running for a few years and
uh that's like trying to swim with an
anchor tighter on your ankle uh it's a
bad plan so let's go at this a different
way what is the net profit on his
business um he pays himself a salary but
no what's the net profit on the business
on average over the last uh four years
is around
250 okay a million two is a little Rich
yeah okay we know that part of it we're
just we're in the beginning process and
we're trying to figure so here's how I
have here's how I've taught some people
who hand the business to the Next
Generation and want to be bought out or
they have to the employee an employee or
a buyer like you that want to be bought
out I don't want you to get payments on
a million to and fouchy decide we're
having another quarantine
me neither okay that'll put you into
bankruptcy court sir it did a bunch of
people and cuz nobody making signs they
were making plexiglass but they weren't
making signs MH so you were screwed if
this was if you'd done this two years
ago so learn a lesson from that now what
you can do is agree to pay him 80 or 90%
of the profits after you take a basic
small salary out mhm until he gets his
million and about of millions about what
it's worth but if you made 250,000 a
year on it and you gave him 90% of it
you'd have him paid out in four and a
half years versus getting his loan per
se exactly and he get his money really
really fast that way but you're living
on a a wage to get till you get him off
your back but if profits go down you're
only committed to giving him a
percentage of profits so you're not
you're not bankrupt then SBA will come
take your house dude
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds. for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
40% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
[Applause]
apply
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
225 well it's Christmas time Merry
Christmas you can get meaningful gifts
for Christmas during our $12 sale right
now our bestselling books The Total
Money Makeover baby steps mil ion John's
number one bestseller the first one he
did own your past change your future all
just $112 the questions for human cards
conversations the Christmas edition is
back uh they sold out really quick last
year we've got the New Year's Eve
Edition to for your friends and family
it's a lot of fun meaningful gift for
everyone there check it out ramseys
solutions.com
store Maggie's in Atlanta hi Maggie
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks so much for taking
my call sure what's up hey so I'm just
calling today I've been listening for
about 2 to three months now um I'm 20
years old I've been doing an every
dollar budget uh for about a month now
and I am needing to get my own place um
in I mean ASAP and I don't even know the
first place to start preparing for it um
my income is fairly low and my monthly
bills are pretty high so I just wanted
to call in and and your advice my income
is um 2,300 monthly what do you
do um I process medical records right
now okay and you're 20 years old yes sir
20 and I only have a high school a high
school diploma okay are you looking for
new work because your income
sucks yeah yeah it it does um I I I've
been looking around to see what I can do
um but with no no degree and no degree
is not a hold back at all yeah I I live
in rural Tennessee I saw a sign the
other day that said McDonald's said $20
an
hour yeah I do I am I do have a side
hustle that I am starting um after the
holidays are over I'm starting a side
hustle and that'll be like $15 an hour
but that's only the weekend that I can
do a side hustle because my job now is a
9 to5 so what what happens after
5 after 5 after 5 is when you work from
5:00 a.m. to 9:00 a.m. when you're broke
that's when you
work yeah um I do have a well I kind of
have a one-year-old my boyfriend um has
a Oney old kind of have a one-year-old
that's
impossible that that's imp that's that's
physically impossible you do it's not
your baby you're
saying yes your boyfriend has a
one-year-old mhm yeah well that's not
I'm sorry B you're broke you're not
you're not babysitting your boyfriend's
kid when you're broke and you got to get
a place to live and you don't have you
don't have the money
right I don't think I have the money to
no no um right now I'm living with my
sister um I've been out on my own since
I was like 17 18 I've been living in
people's rooms and just renting rooms
and now I kind of want a place for just
me and my boyfriend and his son no no no
no no no no no no no no no you you
you're not in a position to be taking
care of
people no no no If he if he wants to get
married and take care of you we'll talk
about it what does he
make he's not working right now oh this
is real good Maggie Maggie are you
hearing yourself out loud firefighter
yes sir yeah yes sir if you were if you
if you were talking to your daughter and
your daughter was you you'd smack
her well I wish my mama would have yeah
I know but I mean you you listen to
yourself I'm going to move in with a guy
who has a one-year-old and doesn't work
and I have to take care of the kids and
I'm supposed to take care of these
people I I think you need to go
somewhere where there's
grown-ups he's he why he's not working
right now is he's he's becoming a
firefighter so he that doesn't start
until the beginning of January though so
right now he's just waiting to see so
right now he's not in school to be a
firefighter he's only waiting for
Firehouse he's going to be doing so why
is he sitting on his butt during
Christmas yeah yeah it's a good question
should be driving for Uber from 5: to 8
5:00 a.m. to 8: a.m. date my daughter
you work and then work all day and then
delivering pizzas at night because
that's what men do when they don't have
a job and they have a
one-year-old yeah yeah and he hasn't he
hasn't worked for about like eight
months now I can almost guarantee you I
can almost guarantee you he's not going
to the fire academy you know how I know
firemen don't live like
that that's not the character of a
fireman I know those men and those women
they have they have they work their fire
shifts and then they have another job
and they have another job on top of that
you know why because they are so
invested in working and going out and
serving their
communities I can almost guarantee you
he won't go to the fire academy no he's
already gone hadn't
he well he's waiting to hear back he
hasn't started no Dave he's he hasn't
even started the fire academy he hasn't
worked for eight months that that I
thought he just finished he was waiting
to get ass a job hold on he has a
one-year-old how's he not worked for
eight months have you supported
him yeah oh his mom his mom does a lot
and then mag Maggie honey Maggie please
talk listen to two old farts okay both
of us have daughters run run as fast as
you can run oh no oh yes I don't think I
hear that okay I'm sorry I can't help
you darling you're Running Blind into
the wall and you're going you're going
you're going to blow the car up when you
hit it oh I'm sorry honey you you've
been a Survivor you bounced from room to
room you left home at 17 years old your
mama didn't tell you not to do this
stuff two guys who love you and love our
daughters are telling you if you were
our daughter we would get rid of Mr
fireman he he would just disappear
somewhere we wouldn't be able to find
him you're being prayed upon sweetheart
I'm telling you this is not going to
happen all right and so uh you need an
ugly angry older brother or father like
one of us and we would tell him to go
away and if he didn't we'd help you go
away cuz you got the stuff to go get it
done in the marketplace girl you can go
out there get you three jobs get you an
apartment start you a life start taking
a degree field I'll send you a copy of
Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose you can start working on your
career you're sharp talking to you but
your judge of men is
sucks and when you have have a man with
a one-year-old who's responsible he
doesn't work for8 months we call that a
dead beat a
burnout and if you ever listen to me
talk or listen to my show I'm overly
compassionate and I've got zero
compassion for a man who's got a toddler
who is letting a 20-year-old girl living
in a her sister's house take care of
them zero none zero Z zero you have a
daughter you have a
child yeah my goodness I I I I please
Maggie he should be ashamed of himself
man but but you're you're not going to
do it and you're going to learn the hard
way and you're going to call me up at 25
and you're going to go yeah you were
right and now I've got all this debt cuz
I went and bought him a car and um and
we rented an apartment and he didn't pay
the bill and the landlord threw us out
and I've got a judgment lean from the
landlord and you're going to be that
caller if you go f through with this
please do not go move in with this guy
if you don't dump him that's your
business uh I think you're on the way to
dumping him you should be but if but for
sure for God's sake quit giving him
money and don't move in with him so and
let's say this so for those of you who
have grown up the last five or six years
you like Maggie you're on your own
you're bouncing from room to room to
room and you spend a lot of time on
social media it appears that things just
happen it appears that bills just get
paid and what you're finding out is oh I
only make
$2,300 but I have an inside job in a
medical community um and it feels like
I'm connected to something bigger and
I'm not working at McDonald's for God's
sakes or I'm not going to throw boxes at
Walmart I would never do that and you're
going to realize that things don't just
happen you have to make enough money
it's a math problem to make enough money
to pay for your rent and for your water
and for your food and for your
electricity and for your car all these
things are very expensive which means
you got to go get one job you got to get
two jobs you got to get three jobs you
develop a plan that is a career where
you don't have to work 80 hours a week
there you go but it takes a few years to
get into that
but most of us um that are older than 30
have worked more than 40 hours like more
than 80 hours the first 5 years of our
working life or 10 of our life um or
more yeah and so um and and that's not a
you're you're you have no life balance
no I have a life that you wish you
freaking had I can tell you that you
just wish you had a tenth of my life but
but I worked my tail endend off to get
here that was a good self- sensor Dave I
got that you got it just right there
right there right there this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of of
getting calls from collection agencies
if private student loan debt is taking
away your financial piece and you don't
see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank y
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan at with Y refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lumpsum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com /
[Music]
Ramsey
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
5225 this show has
um become inordinately successful with
30 million of you so are so out there in
a given month um on YouTube's you know
podcast on uh the various platforms that
680 radio stations that carry us because
we understand that personal finance is
not
math the problem with my
money is the guy I shave
with the mathematics of becoming wealthy
are somewhere you learn them somewhere
around the sixth
grade this is not an intellect problem
this is a behavior problem if I can get
the more Mor on in my
mirror to behave he can be skinny and
Rich but he's got
issues and he engages in stupid people
tricks to the extent that I have
dysfunction in my
relationships I'm going to struggle to
baild wealth to the extent that I have
dysfunction in my beh behaviors like a
lack of work ethic a lack of
Integrity uh other character issues I'm
going to struggle to build
wealth um to the and so there is a tie
in between your emotional
well-being your relational
Acumen uh that is more predictive of
your ability to become wealthy than your
income in other words you it doesn't
matter what you make if you're addicted
to cocaine you're going to lose
everything 100% of addicts as an example
of this discussion end up broke
eventually a
100% eventually some in 10 months some
in 10 years and they lose everything
that's a misbehavior that caused that
it's not a math problem that caused that
it wasn't they didn't understand how
mutual funds work it wasn't that they
didn't earn an income a lot of cocaine
addicts earn a great income um and they
hide their addiction but if if you don't
know how to interact with the opposite
sex and you continually choose poorly in
your mate you are going
to make it almost impossible to create a
sustainable Financial life and I isn't
that weird yeah and I'm just haunted by
like that last call haunts me
because when you say it like you you
won't accept this from your for your own
child everyone goes no I would never
accept that but you just become blind to
it and you just keep doing it you just
keep doing it and you keep doing it and
you wonder you keep going back to the
the the money the money issue why are we
broke why are we broke why are we broke
you got to you got to let this Predator
who is praying on you in your time uh
you got to let him go I ain't doing that
all right well there's not there's not
like a crypto secret we can tell you to
help you make money there's not like a
budgeting hack we can give you um you
and him have to go work It's just tough
man if if you're not connected with your
spouse you're have TR be could be a
relational thing I mean it it's um you
know one of the jokes that we had in the
early days of the show was you know if
you marry a woman that that likes
spending you better enjoy working right
you know and so uh but it's also the
opposite way AB obviously um if you
marry a man that likes spending you
better enjoy working uh and so because
you can't but you can't out earn it and
you can't keep up and the correlation
among millionaires between spouses that
work together and that both shoulder the
load together it's almost 100% of them
yeah there very few people build wealth
dragging a deadbeat along or dragging
someone who's misbehaving in some area
of their life along someone who won't
work someone who can't tell the truth
someone that won't file their taxes uh
someone that uh you know lies all the
time uh you know you just these
dysfunctional people that are in all of
our Lives to the extent that they are uh
that were wrapped up with them pretty
much ensures that we're going to create
a a situation where we can't build a
sustainable financial situation one of
the reasons I've been able to build
wealth is my wife is a freaking Rock
right she's a rock I mean the number the
amount of drama in 43 years I've had at
home when I got home at night with
little kids at home was precisely zero
yeah the only drama my house I bring it
occasionally there was drama before I
got there right but it's not like wait
till your daddy gets home no fear the
wrath of Sharon instead you know I mean
it's like I there is not a you know I
was not having to carry three or four
things around while I was at work I was
carrying work around and it's why we
were able to make such progress yeah
it's it's fun they they say that the one
of the the greatest um determinants for
joy happiness in your life is marrying
well it's the most important decision
you make because marrying poorly um it's
disproportionate how bad your life is
and marrying well it's disproportionate
how wonderful it makes your life but our
friend Dr Henry cloud with the book
boundaries whether it is your marriage
partner or not just the
other people in your life your business
partner your suck the marrow out of your
bones because you won't put up a
boundary right or for some reason don't
know to put up a boundary you weren't
raised in such a way well I was raised
you always take care of daddy well uh
did you notice that your daddy is a
problem right or um well that's just so
and so like stop that's just the way he
is I I would love a great exercise for
folks is to write down the the the top
five to 10 to 15 people in your life
they can be co-workers they can be
family members they can be
friends if you're lucky you got 10 in
this current world we live in if you got
if you're you're exceptionally lucky if
you got 15 write them down and just draw
a line across the paper and say vampire
or contributor is this a person that
when I get done being around them I'm
just like GH or I get done being around
them and I can't wait to go hang out
again they are somebody that that brings
me up and I I challenge you in 202 for
to find Opportunities to be around
vampire people less yeah and be around
those who pour into you who are excited
who challenge you more and that doesn't
mean you get along all the time like
some of the people who contribute most
in my life man we are button heads all
the time and I love them and I I believe
the very similar things with some of the
most vampiric people I just made that
word up that just you get done you're
like golly dude I feel like I was just
slogging through quicksand well I mean
when you come out of a meeting or you
come out of a
social gathering with someone and you
feel like you need to take a shower I
don't want to repeat this right I'm done
right and my wife's like well we need to
be nice no I don't need to be nice we
need to be nice to us so that we not
going to be nice I can be nice from a
further distance I'll wave from over
there you know but this this close
physical proximity with slime is a
problem yeah you know and it's um you
know and it's okay I'm not it's not that
I'm a snob no I like you but I'm not
going to hang out with you yeah I'm it's
it's uh can be nice to you I can help
you I love you I'm not going I can
encourage you but I'm not going you're
not going to be part of my crew that's
right yeah because you become who you
hang around with and if you find out
that you're married to somebody who is
more of a vampire than a contributor
this is the Year let this be the year
that you put that on the table and say
let's build something new let's let's
build something new yeah I'm taking your
sharp teeth yeah well or like the first
caller of of this hour that I'm going to
be clear for the first time cuz I find
myself I don't like you I don't want to
be around around you the things you do
annoy me and I I I kind of H and ha and
hint I've never just been honest with
you I've just never told you let's put
all that on the table this year decide
to uh heal this thing moving forward
because at some point um there are
people in the margins that are
struggling that's not who I'm talking to
I'm talking to most of us most of us at
some point choose the relationships we
have and we choose the the dance that we
choose to do in those things and it's
some at some point somebody's got to
pull pull the pull the rip cord and say
this this one's over this one's over
we're going to
and the reason for the sidebar right now
is this this is the time of year to look
at this and say okay I want you to leave
from this little little rant that we've
done for the last 5 minutes I want you
to leave with this idea who you hang
around with and who you are going to
create relationship with is 100x more
important towards whether you're able to
build wealth than whether you understand
how a mutual fund works or what your
income is they're going to screw up your
life if you let them this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build
wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality host
of the Dr John deloney show one of our
most popular podcasts on the Ramsey
Network number one best-selling author
of building a non-anxious life is the
latest number one that we did with him
it's a great book He's My co-host today
open phones atle
88255 225 Merry Christmas America Travis
is in Baltimore hi Travis how are you
hey John thanks for having me sure um
I'll make this as quick as I can um 31
years old married we have two kids we
don't own a home yet um currently 5
weeks into Financial Peace
University um we've paid off $1,000 of
our debt so far um we have currently
$44,000 in debt um my question for you
is um my previous employer had a profit
sharing system set up uh so um in March
I've been away from them for a year now
I went back over over the road um so in
March I can decide whether I want to
roll that money over to something or if
I want to cash out however I want to do
it I have $551,000 in that account
should I or could I use that money to
wipe out baby step number two and start
baby step number three in 3B I think
that's a qualified plan meaning it's a
retire type of retirement plan am I
right yes so if you cash it out early
you're going to get a 10% penalty Plus
your tax rate so uh what do you make a
year what's your household
income um so I make 100,000 my wife
works parttime she makes about 20 okay
all right and so you're in 35% tax
bracket so you're going to pay 35% plus
10% on the money so it's kind of
mathematically like asking hey Dave I
want to borrow money at 45% interest to
pay off some of my debt that would be a
dumb thing
right so we're not going to do that yeah
we're going to we're going to roll it
over go to Ramsey Solutions and click on
smartvestor Pro and find a good uh a a
good Financial broker in your area that
we recommend that you can sit down with
and help you do that roll over and you
need to roll it over into an IRA and not
pay any taxes on it at all and let it
grow I just don't want to give up half
the money or so to the government in the
name of getting out of debt that's a bad
plan so uh what but you're making 120
and you only owe 44 right M yeah so and
you're just getting started so the good
news is you've gone into attack mode and
if you just keep turning up the heat on
the attack mode you'll probably be dead
free in under two
years okay hey Travis can I challenge
you a
bit I'm sorry can I challenge you a
little bit sure um you've been in the
week you've been in the class five
weeks yeah tonight is uh week number
five yes excellent so you make1 20
grand how have you only paid off a
hundred I mean how have you only paid
off a, bucks do you have a pretty
expensive lifestyle you're
living um well no uh we we started uh
budgeting with every dollar
um
and we literally just started literally
this this John's point is this if you
look at the big number
120 minus
44 would be like
$6,000 if you lived on 76,000 for one
year you'd be debt free not counting
taxes okay right um so that's his point
and that's not $1,000 a month that's
more like $4,000 a month so um I
challenge you to get radical find what
you can sell in your house do you have
tractors I you to lean cars what you got
that's what I'm saying I think you're
going to lean down into that budget if
you did it in two years that's $2,000 a
month but $1,000 a month it's not enough
out of your budget you need to cut more
than that and get after the debt so uh
but all of that to say that's the way to
go John's exactly right and let's go
ahead and roll that money over so you
don't give the government half of that
and go and then just you know beans and
rice rice and beans we're not going out
to eat uh we're not going on vacation
we're going to attack this using the
every dollar budget and we're going to
get it cleared up and for the first time
in your life you're going to be free and
it's going to be worth it it's going to
be a complete pain in the butt for the
next 18 to 24 months but it's going to
be worth it hey thanks for calling in
man Joe's withs Atlanta hi Joe welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hey hey Dave hey John nice to talk
to you guys you too what's up yes so I
got a question this is about 529 plan um
I have two kids one 1614 and then we
just found out we have two coming next
year so we have a total of four yay all
right
yeah yeah yeah pretty exciting um once
we got over the shock of having two at a
time but um so my question is we uh we
have a surplus of funds for this year we
are 100% debt free no mortgage no cars
no Debs of any kind no credit card I
hate it when that happens I know it's
it's hard way to go would you run for
[Laughter]
Congress if uh if I had any interest I
would hear you he's like man I was
thinking Dave but I'm also thinking
about setting myself on fire yeah yeah
yeah yeah um so my question is on the
the Georgia 529 plan it's uh tax
deductible up to 8,000 per kid per
year and we can only have two right now
because I think you need a social
security number for each account you set
you do that's right um would you
recommend so we we have a good amount of
extra um just putting a lump we can put
more in than
8,000 would you consider putting like 50
Grand in for each kid and just being
done with it yeah uh or put it somewhere
else and then every year put a little
bit more in no I mean you can do that uh
the the downside is 529 of course has to
be used for education and any growth on
the money is going to be taxed if you
pull it out for something other than and
penalized if you pull it out for
something other than education so um
that that's your downside so along with
making a commitment to put 50 Grand
which pretty well finishes it up if
you're doing this for young children
that'll be it they can cover they can
cover undergrad with that you're done
check the box you're out and I note they
can I'm not sure if this is a new rule
but you can do 10,000 a year for for a
private school K through 12 I believe
that's that's what it is so if we if we
would do like high school private school
that's true you could drain it down
doing that but but the uh if you don't
put them in private school and they
don't go to college you got some money
trapped in there that's my only point
and that's okay we just say that out
loud which means when I started my kids
college funds they were young like yours
and I just brainwashed them I said this
your college fund it's your college fund
it's your college fund which presupposes
you're going to college and so you know
now we're going to college and study
left-handed puppetry we're going to go
study something that actually works in
the marketplace right we don't want to
get some nuanced useless freaking degree
then be a barista that's not the plan
but uh but yeah we we but yeah all of
that yeah I would do that I would do
that and now with a Georgia 529 do not
do the prepaid tuition you do not do
that you're investing in mutual funds
that you control the
options and that you can decide where
they go to school you're not you're not
trapped in with Prepaid don't do prepaid
that's not a good deal cuz the rate of
return suck on that so um and your
options are very limited
so good question man thanks for
[Music]
calling Hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Ed Ed super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to church Hill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show open phones at
5225 Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host uh Tona is with us in
Philadelphia hi Tona what's up hi um so
I'm calling because I have a question so
I'm 25 years old I'm a single mother um
my income is about 47,000 a year um and
I have about
18,000 um in debt um I have $116,000 of
that is a vehicle that um was they have
it as a repo on my credit because I had
a car accident and it was totaled and
the person who crashed me didn't have
full coverage and I didn't have full
coverage either so I'm sit yeah so I'm
in a situation where the car that I have
right now uh has 192,000 Mi on it so
it's going out on me and I'm in need of
a new vehicle and being that I have that
repo on my credit um I'm having a hard
time getting approved for uh another
vehicle good it's the greatest thing
that ever happened to you honey last
thing you need is a car payment kto
you're
broke yeah but you do need a
car yes hey when you say it's going out
on you my truck has
197,000 miles on it is it just ugly or
is it falling apart no it's not ugly the
um it's just starting to fall apart on
me like I just put 1,500 into it trying
to fix it and it's still giving me
problems okay all right so so the car is
probably worth what
$2,000 no not even with the problems
that it has and you said you make
what about 47 okay how many kids you got
just one how old he's three he's four
okay four who watches him when you
work um he is at a daycare okay so um
yeah cuz I'm what I'm the reason I'm
asking is I'm trying to find you some
money CU I want you to scrape together
like you found the 1500 to fix the car I
want you to scrape together $1,500 to
$2,000 sell your car for $2,000 and buy
a $4,000 car which is a whole lot better
than you've got now but no car
payments okay and then I want you to do
that again about a year from now okay
and I don't want you to drive that car
the rest of your life but it but car
payments are going to hold you back so
much it sounds like it's going to be
you're just so sick of having a crappy
car that's unreliable and the stress
that goes with that that it makes you
jump ahead and in your mind just having
something that's reliable is worth the
pain of the payment and I'm trying to
tell you before you get there it's
not yeah no I'm just getting to the
point where like I'm a little frustrated
yeah you know you're a lot frustrated I
would be frustrated with you I I
understand and I agree with your
frustration I don't want it to lead you
to a bad decision and it's about to so
let's avoid car payments I'm so glad you
did not get approved because if you had
gotten approved it would have been at a
high ripoff subprime interest rate
because you have a repo on your
record yeah and so you would have been
screwed
double yeah yeah don't do that to
yourself yourself let's go pay cash for
a the the difference in a $4,000 car and
a $2,000 car is very
dramatic yeah okay now are you in a good
church um I do I do attend a church do
you have some guys around anywhere that
could be your ugly Uncle for a day or
two and help you help you pick out a
reliable car uh and and uh not let
someone mess with you because they think
they can but instead ugly Uncle standing
there uh and saying you know uh this is
this car is not real pretty but it's a
really good reliable mechanical car
that's the one you buy when you're
buying a $4,000 car we're not trying to
buy sex appeal we want
reliability of course yeah and sometimes
when you're negotiating with someone on
that people are
sexist and and they they'll do stuff for
an old ugly uncle they wouldn't do for a
sweet young
lady yeah or put a note in your church
bulletin or let your folks know I'm
looking for a great $3500 car single
with a three-year-old and I need a
reliable $44,000 car would someone help
me find
one okay you'll have people that raise
their hand yeah you might have somebody
give you one hey by the way you don't
like asking for help do you I'm not um I
am actually a police officer so that um
you like hard for me to be that kind of
person to you know like reach out and
ask for help all right hold on I want
this is important you have cast quote
unquote those kind of people as people
who ask for
help I want you to reframe that I want
you to know that the wisest people I
know ask other wise people for support
and help about things they don't
know okay and so it's not those people
that ask for help it's you it's me it's
Dave it's all of us the wisest people I
know reach out to other wise people and
say hey what do you think about this can
you help me out with this and so this is
you stepping I don't go in and negotiate
on something myself and I'm a really
good business guy and a real good
negotiator but I don't go into an an
item or a situation that I know nothing
about the I don't have any expertise in
I bring along the old ugly Uncle
myself okay and that's a really ugly
Uncle for Dave to bring
in
if Dave says he's an ugly Uncle oh my
God yeah well yes yeah that but I mean
you know that's you bring in the heavy
you bring in somebody beside you and so
if I'm negotiating on a tech thing I
don't know nothing about tech I got 400
people that work here that do that
though and so I'm going to bring in my
top guy who's going to razzled Dazzle
him with his academic and says all the
tech words right and and they like oh
God these people know what they're doing
you know but when they're looking at me
they're pretty sure I don't don't well
and similarly um I I guess I guess the
uh the appearance is we have all the
answers to every one of life's questions
a bunch of Acres behind my place went up
for sale and I immediately thought oh
yeah I know a guy his name is Dave and I
work with him and so I said Dave this is
what they're asking and you said that's
too much and so I moved on right and so
it's it's every wise person I know asks
other wise people I don't know anybody
that knows Middle Tennessee real estate
better than you do and so why would I I
would be foolish to not ask ask you that
question right so ask people in your
life for support and help however you
can man whether it's wisdom or whether
it's hey I need you to come help me do
this thing that I can't I you can do it
better I can do it better with you than
I can do it by myself that's right
that's all we're saying and yeah and
thank you thank you for being a
policeman in Philadelphia police woman
in Philadelphia police person whatever
we call that I don't know I cannot
figure out how to do but anyway uh but
anyway I I was trying to be nice and
then John screwed it up got all W yeah
all right
anyway yeah good stuff open phones atle
225 so guys here's the thing cars her
situation with cars is a big deal we did
the exact thing I did exactly this a guy
loaned me a car that was probably worth
$300 cuz I didn't have a car well I had
one and I needed a second one and it was
a 19 78 Cadillac with 478,000 actual
miles on it the vinyl roof was torn
loose across the front so when you drove
it it filled up with air and looked like
a flying parachute and the predominant
color was Bondo that's the car I was
driving when you're driving that car
anything is moving up $1,000 car is is
A1 th000 car is moving way up and I got
a1 th000 car I did and I gave my buddy
his car back it was a loaner he loaned
it to me for a month and I found a
thousand dollar miraculously because I
wasn't driving
that I had been driving a jaguar and I
went bankrupt and now I'm driving Bondo
buggy with a parachute on top and but I
drove it to $1,000 and then three months
later I bought a $3,000 car five months
later I bought a $10,000 car and every
time I just move up a little bit but the
difference in a $10,000 car and a
$11,000 car is very dramatic it's
significant yeah it's very dramatic I
can none of that was with car payments I
get I did it picture you driving down
the street honking the horn look Shar I
got $1,000 when you pull up to the
stoplight and your top is settling and
people are looking at you you just turn
up the rap music right I mean come on
man this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Merry
Christmas Ramsey Show question of the
day is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for home services from repairs and
maintenance to Remodeling and upgrades
neighborly trusted home service
providers have trained local experts to
handle almost any job great company
download the neighborly app and connect
today all right today's question comes
from Sandra in Florida Sandra writes my
spouse's spending is crippling our
finances and our marriage each month we
have only about 5 to 600 left after
monthly bills and minimum debt payments
and we only have $1,000 saved I've tried
to speak lovingly to my husband and let
him know how much the overspending
scares me and affects my mental health
I've also had moments of frustration
have blamed him for financial struggles
which I realized is not a healthy
approach seems all my efforts and
approaches are futile I understand the
Ramsey principles behind join accounts
and have lived this way for years but at
what point in my marriage do I say
enough and separate myself financially
right before divorce yeah yeah and I
think we're here I think we're close
this is way bigger Dave than uh I'm glad
she I'm glad she had the courage to
write is crippling our finances and our
marriage because this type of behavior
tells me there's other issues in that
marriage it's not just
money yeah this guy is um kind of got
the axis of the world stopped through
the top of his head everything spins
around him he's the most important thing
that ever lived I'm telling you his mama
told him that yep and um and now uh
nobody tells him
anything yeah
um I just can't imagine Dave I again I
don't have a psychology for this I can't
imagine Sheila taking me out and saying
um anything I'm doing you're scaring me
to death
and me going yeah I don't care I I
just I don't have that in my I don't
have that in my body I don't understand
that I don't understand how you could
respond to to anybody that way if if the
if the waitress at at Waffle House sat
down and said hey the way you're doing
things scares me and I'm not I don't
feel safe I I don't think I could be
like I don't care I I I just don't have
that in me man so I don't understand
this dude at all what a scumbag I just
don't get it
don't get it so
um yeah the it could be just immaturity
could be a lot of things um in all
seriousness all once I get past all my
frustration and my name calling but um
the
um so there's two issues with this email
number one uh you guys need to sit down
with the marriage counseler and if he
won't go go by yourself so that you can
start to get language to how you're
going to
decide how much longer you're going to
do this uh because my experience with
this and I'm not a counselor and I'm not
trained like John is but for 30 years
I've done this and sat with couples and
my experience is particularly ladies
more so than men uh they reach an end
point and it boils and boils and boils
and then suddenly they go over the edge
and the switch flips and once it flips
there's no getting her back right she
done when she she's done and she like
like roadkill it's over it's done and
you can't get it back and you're going
to reach that boiling point and if you
don't do it intentionally with some help
with a good coach a good marriage
counselor to give you words to do this
in a very wise and reasonable way it's
all it's going to sneak up on you and
him and you're just going to go I'm done
when somebody says the word futile
everything I've tried yeah is for not is
for nothing yeah that's lost hope that's
lost hope that's right yeah and uh so
you're you're getting really close and
I'm telling you if there's a chance that
you save this marriage it's going to be
with some help guiding you through how
to communicate to him if you can get
through to Jello brain here and get him
to do this okay now if you can and you
turn it around that's great that's thing
one that's the route to
go hidden inside of this email is the
question that I've been asked a bunch of
times is a separate issue this how can I
handle my money separately in a messed
up marriage and it be okay and the
answer is you can't you've got to make
the marriage okay if you want to have
prosperity in your relationships and
prosperity in your net worth it has to
be done from a functional standpoint not
surviving a bunch of misbehavior and
still prospering in spite of it that
just doesn't happen in my experience we
we see almost never does someone
overcome this guy not changing and
somehow you create a tactical way to
separate your money and while you're
still married to him and he continues to
do the exact same thing somehow you go
off and become a millionaire that does
not
happen that's just that's mythology
there's not a tactic a legal document a
process that causes you to be able to
swim with an anchor around your
ankle and and so you guys have got to
work through this or work your way out
of it to be able to have a great life
for both of you and he's I think it's
important to call out this husband is
not um being a person of fidelity he is
not upholding the marriage vows that
said Till sickness um to sickness and
health um till death do his part um this
is ours mine is yours and yours is mine
he's not doing that um he saying I
really don't care about you I just don't
I just don't um
and breaks my heart for you Sandra break
my heart sad very sad Josh is in
Illinois hi Josh what's
up hi Dave I really appreciate you
giving me your time I'm gonna try to
make this quick sure so in
2021 uh so my family and I have always
used a tax assistant uh to file our
taxes now in
2021 apparently the taxes of both my dad
and myself were filed
incorrectly um and basically it's
showing on at first the cp2000 notice
now it's cp3219a uh it's showing uh
zerar was shown on return for several of
my employers and then when it says
reported by others and then it gives how
much money I I paid and the increase in
tax or the deficiency on this is
9548 and then a substantial tax
statement penalty is
$583 now my question is so the guy that
did your taxes calculated your taxes
wrong uh that may very well be the case
and as is that what you're telling me
I'm asking you I'm making sure I
understand what you're
saying yes yes the taxes were filed
incorrectly okay and so you have a
$10,000 tax bill that you didn't think
you
had right and this was from 2021 and
ever since 2021 even though they just
found it they've been charging interest
and yeah that's what they
do yeah but but but the bottom line is
is if they had been filed correctly you
would have owed
$10,000 uh correct we we received um we
received the refund that we probably
should not have received yet right and
did you go and have you had another tax
professional look at the return and make
sure that the
irs's uh Proclamation is
accurate yes sir and and here's the
thing actually we we know it's we know
that this is accurate because um it it
was a lady that did our returns that
year we are actually doing business
right now with her sister and not only
did this original lady ghost our family
over all this she's not even talking to
her sister anymore and her and her
sister had a fallen out over this that's
doesn't mean anything doesn't matter
doesn't matter I'm asking the question
have you had a tax professional that
knows what the flip they're doing this
time actually go over this return and
verify that you do owe $9,500 plus
penalties yes and so the sister is
reliable right yes you think why is she
an enrolled agent a CPA what is
she uh she is an enrolled agent okay all
right so you had a tax bill all along
you just didn't know it and it's cost
you 500 bucks in addition to that you're
just going to pay it man I mean there's
not a lot you can do about
this they're not liable for your tax
bill because they calculated it
wrong are they liable for the penalty
maybe you might get 500 bucks out of
them but I it's not worth the dead gum
trouble everybody in this story makes no
sense yeah so you know yeah I I I would
just pay it I mean you could get an
attorney try to get 500 bucks out of the
dead beat if you want but I don't that's
not you'll pay more than $500 in fees
you're going to have pay more than $500
to have the
meeting this is the ramsy
[Music]
sh
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Renee and Edward are with us
in Albuquerque New Mexico hey guys how
are you okay we're good how are you good
how can we
help well so last year my wife ran in an
apartment and the uh she's really sick
she has bold poisoning she went and the
property manager guaranteed her an
apartment that was bold free uh she
moved in uh three weeks later had to
move out go to the emergency room
extremely sick from mold she hired a
independent mold inspector who came in
found you know test results showed that
the place was unlivable uh toxic mold
and needed remediation so the property
manager said she could move out pay an
extra month's rent and she'd release her
from her lease agreement well yesterday
she we get a call from the uh credit
companies a credit collector and saying
she owes them almost
$4,000 and um it's 5,000 well right
they're willing to settle for 3,800 so
I'm I'm confused why your wife moved out
and rent an apartment I'm
confused cuz we were separated oh okay
that makes sense and now you're back
together
right um yeah because of
this because of the
mold uh because I had nowhere to
go okay so my question Dave is
should they're threatening that this if
she doesn't pay this it'll ruin her
credit which obvious but should she pay
them uh we fight it should she not worry
about her credit but but I can't work
right now I'm still very very sick so I
can't
work okay
um what is your all's financial
situation I assume you don't have any
money well I mean we're debt free uh I
work he makes he makes good money he
makes plenty money yeah I mean she she
lives with me um she she doesn't work
she's sick um but when she gets well she
wants to move out so she doesn't want
her credit ruined yeah okay well
obviously the lesson learned is you
didn't get it in writing you got a
verbal from the landlord right right
right so that's the lesson learned this
would have been a lot easier uh the
landlord is an individual or a manager
of a
complex is a property manager of the
complex but not the property management
company which is the one trying to
collect the
right the fees but this guy's an
employee of
them yeah yeah okay all right so
um hard ball would sound like this uh
contact an
attorney um the first thing I would do
is the two of you get in the car r over
and meet with this manager that made you
this
promise okay in person and say look you
told me we were out now I'm getting half
hassled for five grand here this is the
I'm not going to pay the five grand you
told me we were out I'll put you on the
stand as a witness and if you unless
you're willing to perjure yourself which
is a criminal act you will tell the
court that you said I was out of the
lease at which point I will be out of
the lease and so you need to get with
your team over here and get this
collections effort stopped and I need
inwriting from you in the next couple of
days that this is all going away and
there's no problem if you do that I will
not sue you for my medical bills because
you misled me and put me in an apartment
with mold if you do not do this and I'm
not out of this instantly my attorney is
going to sue you personally sue your
company for my lost wages and my medical
bills and for release of this but I
don't want to play that I would rather
you just keep your word and your company
keep your word and release me and we'll
go on our
way right in person very clear do not
raise your voice do not use swear words
but very direct with deep eye contact
representing
anger you follow me this over ago and
that you know that's assumption that
that same I don't care this is your best
place to start this is the cheapest way
to fix
this okay because people that think when
you get lawyers and you get into the
court system that you get Justice there
is no such thing the only one that gets
Justice is the lawyer's kid whose
tuition gets paid by
you okay this is not going to go
anywhere else so but if you have to hire
an attorney and go after these people
you go after them for your lost wages
because they fraudulently misrepresented
and cost you your
health so we're not only going to go for
release of the lease we're going to go
for compensation on top of that we're
going to make your freaking life
miserable if you make me make a hobby
out of
you all right yeah we don't want to do
any of this you don't want to do it I
don't want to do it they don't want to
do it and they need to hear that real
clearly from you the best thing they can
do is just get quickly get me a piece of
paper that says I owe you zero and I
will simultaneously release you from
your liability for lying to me and
making me
sick
yeah I'd probably have a manila folder
with your medical bills the the report
from the mold folks too and I would ask
him in that office to print off all of
the bills he sent you over the last
calendar year because it's probably GNA
be
zero okay all right so so subsequent to
that let let's assume that that person
is no longer employed there which is
most likely with the scenario well then
talk to the current manager there and
tell them what happened and tell them
what you're going to do and let that
manager see if if I'm the manager
sitting there and you tell me that I'm
going to the regional manager who turned
this over to collections and go look the
doofus that was here before me screwed
this lady she's giving us an opportunity
to get off light we need to let her
go right okay in in the event they don't
get a
lawyer well okay but the collection guy
the guy from the collection company he's
an
idiot of their they're no longer
involved like it's
now bull crap that's what they all say I
don't give a crap what the collection
agency is an idiot just move on that
guy's he sits in a cubicle and calls
people that don't pay their bills all
day he's got no power at
all okay the company turned this over to
collections they did not sell it they
still own the problem they just hired a
Hitman the hitman's got no ability to do
anything but pull the trigger you don't
negotiate with the Hitman you go to the
mob boss and get the Hitman called off
yeah you're right and all of this sits
on some manufactured principle you guys
are carrying around that I just want to
burst a little bubble for you who cares
about your stupid credit nobody cares
don't borrow money and whenever you
decide to move back out you're going to
need first in last month's rent so
you're going have to figure out work
you're going to figure out money and
then you're going to pay them you're
going to move on with your life yeah
yeah right but if I don't have credit
how could I do that right you don't need
credit you don't need credit that's a
that's a people buy people rent
apartments every day without credit with
first and last month's
rent really because everything I've ever
tried they wanted to to see my really we
called 22 Apartments the other day
around here as a test and found every
one of them but two would rent to you
and that was over the phone that was
just over the phone without even tell I
mean I'm move I'm new I'm moving to town
I'm moving out my husband and I are
separating I've got a job I make first
and last month's rent I got no
credit and and they'll rent to you you
know and just go on now corporate idiots
like you've been dealing with are the
ones that won't they'll pull a credit
bureau on you but look you've got to go
deal with this if you don't deal with it
it's not going to get anything but worse
and so get over there go why not it's
Christmas time go over there this week
sit down go look if it's the that
was here before you dude it's not your
fault but he made a promise and we're
going to hold your company to that
promise uh and if you don't then we're
going to sue you for the health
issues and and you know I don't I'm I'm
not contacted an attorney yet but I'm
leaving here and going to contact one
unless you tell me you think you can get
this fixed and every email that was sent
around this is going to be public record
so all those emails that he sent his
bosses everything anybody ever said on a
text or on an email is going to be part
of the deposition let them know we're
going to completely give you an anal
exam that's what's going to happen get
ready and and that that's how that's
what lawsuits look like there ain't no
fun nobody enjoys the process oh my
gosh this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solution it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is
our co-host today number one bestselling
author of the book no own your past
change your future and the latest one
building a non-anxious life he's also
the host of the Dr John delone show
where we talk about mental health issues
and relationship things so we're here to
help you today guys Merry Christmas glad
you're with us aie is up this hour
Aussie's in El Paso Texas hi Aussie how
are you he's going off the rails onself
Dave thank you for uh taking my call
this is really awesome cool I was GNA
make an Aussie Osborne joke but I
screwed up so there we go what's up
azy hey guys I was start listening to
you guys like about three months ago
with my wife uh we saw you guys on
YouTube and I think this is the best
thing ever well thank you um thank you
Dave uh so we're working on uh baby
steps and basically we have about
$25,000 in student debt and $20,000 in
car
loans and um basically my question is
should I extend my lease in my apartment
to pay those off and then get a house
yes or should I put it down pay okay
yeah you you we tell folks not to buy a
house while you're in debt because it's
going to cause you to buy a different
house than you would buy if your debt
free and and if you move into a house
with a bunch of student loan payments
and a car payment the first week you're
there the hot water heater will go
out okay yeah you just you want to have
everything cleaned up to where when you
move into the house the house is a
blessing so yeah extend your extend your
lease and lean in get on that every
dollar budget cut down to no nothing on
your lifestyle let's get this debt
cleaned up as fast as you can so it
sounds like you got 40 something
thousand in debt did I hear that right
yes sir okay and what's your house old
income uh we make about 120 okay so how
fast do you think you're going to pay
this
off uh really fast what's really
fast uh I think maybe eight months
eight yes I love that you are down to
nothing I like it not a boy man get it
that's that's intensity right there man
and be weary of people who know how much
money you make and are wondering why
you're living like you're living right
if you live Spartan and people are going
to say like man you got all this buddy
you don't need to just put your head
down put your head down and get it done
keep it going that's you man that's
that's the number right there I love it
you can do this in one year or less I'll
calling you a stud okay have at it do it
that's the best thing you can do the
faster you get clear the faster you get
save a down payment and an emergency
fund and the faster you get your house
and so you're probably about two years
from buying a house which is perfectly
fine no problem with that at all Charles
is with us in Jacksonville Florida hey
Charles how are how are
you doing well thanks so much guys
really uh better than I deserve I guess
and uh just wanted to say thank you
first of all Dave we're on baby step six
we've got six kids and you really just
changed our lives our family's lives so
first and foremost thank you for for all
of that well thank you way to go man I'm
proud of you absolutely absolutely so
quick quick question for you we I'm
supporting my my mom financially she's
got some retirement but but really kind
of not a lot of savings um we've been
able to get her to pay off all her debt
and just been very fortunate and
bringing her on board as well she does
have a $200,000 whole life policy uh
that she got back in 1996 she probably
put about yeah 60,000 or so into it at
this point um and it just jacked up in
price there's no cash value in it so
it's 425 a month not something that
there's no cash
value there's no cash value yeah that's
that's I've been looking into it I I
always knew it was there but I I
realized it was kind of a mess and um W
you know and what makes this more
complicated is is she and my dad had uh
both got into this um back in 96 and he
passed away about eight nine years ago
and they had ended his um policy 10
months before he passed away so they had
sunk a lot of money into that one too
but they couldn't afford it anymore they
um yeah so so okay this is not an
investment it's just a bad
story yes so just cancel it just cancel
it unless she's is she terminally
ill she's not and we've looked at
selling the policy no no don't don't get
into vi etical just sell it ju just
close it just shut it down just a bad
idea you got a hole in your pocket quit
putting money in the
pocket yeah absolutely it's uh is there
any to convert it into a term I mean is
there anything we can do that it's just
no it's got no cash value if you convert
it to a term she you got a term
insurance policy on an old lady it's
going to be expensive I mean yeah life
insurance is based on
age the older you are the more likely
you are to die and the higher the
premiums are it's a pretty simple
formula right absolutely and she's in
relatively good health so so I mean if
you try to if you try to get a Term
Policy that's what you're going to into
is my point and she doesn't need a bunch
of life insurance she's not supporting
anyone if she passes away you're taking
care of
her absolutely I I should say I'm sorry
when she passes away we all are going to
pass away none of us get out of
here so yeah I mean it's just a matter
of timing and and the bottom line is she
just owns a bad financial product that
she never needed but for sure doesn't
need
now absolutely yeah mourning the loss of
that $60,000 yeah that's what's that's
what's causing you hesitation you're
still trying to get something out of
this and say God we got screwed and I
don't want to admit it move on yeah and
you know I was I was 10 at the time or
whatever right and yeah uh certainly
that 60,000 could have grown to a lot
more right now I mean you know it would
have been it would have been a ton of
money yeah it would had your mom and dad
both would have had so much money if
they' bought inexpensive term insurance
and done real investing instead of
getting screwed by some whole life agent
probably some guy they
knew crazy that it's legal and looking
back I mean obviously I didn't know any
of this when I was 10 but they're the
payday lender of the middle
class yeah and here's the here's the
deal though here's the deal the first
step I put in my book about building a
non-anxious life is you have to choose
reality because what you're doing is
you're spinning up stories you're angry
you're thinking about what could have
been I was 10 years old and all that
does is spin up your body you go to war
on a battle you can't fight yeah there's
no there's no there's no winning here
it's just ending it just stop just stop
it's just you know oh I put I put I put
$60,000 in my pocket there was a hole in
it I lost the
$6,000 now what do I do now well you sew
up the hole and you don't put any more
money in that pocket until you sew up
the hole so we're canceling this stupid
thing and run the guy off with a stick
that's all you're doing it's it is that
simple I'm sorry man I'm sorry your
parents got ripped off yeah I hate that
but I mean it's Car
leasing uh whole life life insurance
time
shares um I mean these are the things
that just eat credit cards or the credit
card interest rates oh my God they just
eat people's lunch they just tear them a
pieces man and uh you know when you
actually understand how these products
work you go God that is a legalized
fraud but it is legal it's perfectly
legal it's just a horrible product never
ever buy life insurance ever that has a
savings component to it of any kind
there's not a place there's not a time
that it works there only one person that
works for that's the life insurance
company that's it it's screwing you 100%
of the time hope I wasn't
[Music]
unclear
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
5225 thank you for joining us America
Merry Christmas to you Jason is in San
Antonio Texas love your town Jason
what's up thank you sir first off I will
start off by thanking you you've uh
changed my life um on our last three
real estate transactions we've
definitely been blessed and we are on
baby step s uh thank God way to and um
thank you sir um we are in a position
where we could potentially be looking at
a real estate investment and uh I know
you have prolific experience in
investing and I wanted to ask your
opinion on um setting up potentially a
business to uh invest in like an LLC or
under my name and then how to properly
find uh investment properties to invest
in and then uh obviously uh you know how
do we how do we manage it um you know do
we do flips do we do rentals uh what's
your opin opion on stuff like that okay
um well there's a lot of different
things you can do there that's a whole
real estate course you're talking about
in a sense but the uh
um I as you probably have already
figured out I'm unusual and I pay cash
for all mine or I don't buy it so that's
thing one uh I do put all of our
properties um in an LLC we don't buy
residential houses anymore in our
situation we've got a bunch of them but
not adding any when we were buying those
we uh would put uh up to $5 million
worth into an LLC and then we would form
another LLC the reason for that is if an
LLC owns the rental house the tenant
gets drunk and falls off the porch and
decides it's your fault and sues you
they have to sue the owner of the
house which is the
LLC exactly okay and if they they were
to win they can take what that LLC owns
but nothing
else so your other assets like your
personal residents are then protected so
by putting your properties up to a
certain point in an LLC and then if once
the Target on the LLC gets too big you
do another LLC so I've got a bunch of
them
um like I've got one building that's a
$15 million office building it's its own
LLC okay you see what I'm doing but if
somebody Falls over there the worst case
scenario if they get past the insurance
they get past me pip paying lawyers to
sue them for being stupid and so on the
most they're going to get is that
building you follow me yes that Mak
sense so if you're going to buy a house
or two form an LLC throw them in there
now then as far as whether you're
flipping them or whether you're U uh
uh holding them then that's a completely
different strategy in in terms of what
you're looking for uh and what you want
to do and that kind of stuff flipping is
um been made famous of course by cable
television everybody thinks they're
chipping
Joan and um I've probably done 2,500
flips in my life but mostly in another
life before I did this I hardly ever
sell a piece of real estate now
I buy it and hold it
forever and so uh flips are a pain in
the butt um because you're basically in
the business of renovating properties
and reselling them finding another one
renovating it and reselling it if you
want to do that as your business that's
okay but it it's time consuming you know
you're running Subs you're running paint
colors picking faucets it's like
building a dadgum house you know I mean
you're you're going to pick roofs you're
going to do all these things and then
pull building permits you're going to
have to do all this stuff depending on
how much work is being done to the house
and in and the proximity or to a to a a
city the the municipality that you got
to do that so you got to go through all
that stuff um and you after you get
through all of that you can make some
money doing it if you bought the thing
right so um you just decide if you want
to do that or not on rentals the best
rates of return are cheap
properties but they're the highest
hassle in other words the more expensive
the rent typically the classier the
tenant right more stable yeah and the
more stable but if you got lower income
property you know you're having to fight
all kinds of other misbehaviors and
other stuff in the properties but the
returns are
excellent uh
so fact 120 125,000 is about what we
have left over from the most recent sale
and I just parked it in an S&P not
knowing what to do with it we take that
and buy you know buy one or you want to
buy one flip it or you and and roll it
up into something but think about what
it is you want to own for 10 years if
you're buying a
rental right and from personal
experience I'll tell you you you know
you're a brand new landlord you don't
want to deal with lower income property
it's pain in the
butt I mean you it's it becomes its own
business it's your own you have to have
a a a brain adjustment when you do it
because you have to think
different um but it you know all the all
the residential I have today is is
really high-end single families and I
don't how I got 10 or 15 of them I don't
have a bunch of them most of our stuff
is commercial but uh but uh uh so all of
that to say you just got to decide what
you want to do the but the more
um don't underestimate the hassle factor
of what you're stepping into
a flip is a big hassle I'm telling you
you make some money but it's a job uh
you know dealing with lower income
people you can make a great rate of
return but it's a hassle it becomes a
job and it requires a cultural
adjustment in your brain because they're
it's a different um psyche that you're
dealing with as a customer and so um you
know by and large not all the time but
as a
generalization uh call it a stereotype
if you want to but then uh uh and then
the same thing on the other end so but
if you're going to buy something to hold
look at it and go how's this going to
age in 10 years is it already 50 years
old oh then it's going to be 60 years
old when it's 10 years from now you're
going to start to you know so how old
are you Dave I know but I'm talking
about houses I mean I look at the house
I grew up in and I think that stinking
house how old it is now oh yeah you know
I mean wow I wouldn't buy that house now
oh yeah you know that's that's old yeah
same the one I grew up in yeah you know
so that that's the thing but it's a
great question um a and uh and but I
think the biggest mistake this frenzy we
have John of people and Jason the people
we have out here wanting to buy real
estate right now the biggest mistake is
is that they they probably understand
about 10% of how hard it's going to be
well I like the way you're framing it
because you're saying you're asking what
life do you want and then we're gonna
we're GNA buy a house or flip a house
based on that because if you want to get
in there and get your hands dirty and
deal with knocking on doors and hey you
can't do this you can't light fires in
the yard what that's a life right and
some people you can't run drugs out of
our house that's right and if you want
to mess with subs and have fun with
doing that and flipping it and pick
faucets and that brings you or your
whoever your business partner's Joy
knock your lights out but that's a
different kind of life right yeah if you
want to set it but this idea on Tik Tok
that you can just buy houses and I've
got this passive income people who say
passive income on real estate are morons
right there's nothing passive about
owning real estate it's active right
it's very active there's no I don't own
a single piece of property that's
passive right and I own about several
hundred million dollars worth oh my God
it's not passive there's nobody there's
nothing that what passive is is mutual
funds they send me a statement in my
inbox that's all I do deal with there's
that's passive but no there's not any
there's no real estate passive income
that's a that's a that's somebody trying
to sell you a get rich quick seminar on
Tick Tock or Tic Tac or whatever the
flip it is you know so that that's the
you know you just real estate is a
wonderful investment but do not go into
it folks with rosecolor glasses think
it's going to be easy it's a process
you're going to get rich quick it's not
quick it's not easy there's a hassle
it's not a pro it's a problem
it's you know it's like starting your
own business it's the it's the meanest
boss you'll ever work for in your life
the guy will work you into the ground
you know don't start your own business
and think it's going to fix all your
problems it just makes all your problems
come home to on your plate this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
la
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here Jeremy
and dalphin are with us on the debt-free
stage in the lobby of ramsy solutions
how are you guys blessed better better
amazing I love it very fun where do you
guys live
yeah go ahead okay wah hatti Texas which
is it's about 20 minutes south of Dallas
just down 35 okay okay that 287 yeah
exactly look at you Texas people talking
code all right I love it way to go guys
congratulations welcome to Nashville
Merry Christmas how much debt did you
pay off
8,849 183 I love it how long did this
take 57 months okay way to go and uh
your range of household income during
that 57 months um it was 65k to about
110k neat what do youall do for a living
we're we're both teachers and I'm
actually a high school football coach oh
wow very good good for you guys so what
kind of debt was the 129 uh it was a
mixture of school loans there was a we I
owed something to the uh some money to
the IRS there was a car loan uh credit
cards there was a old medical bill uh
and a pasted uh eviction from my col
days okay cool very good way to go you
guys excellent so uh what happened 57
months
ago I was uh just I was actually
teaching uh like multiple math classes
one of them was a financial math course
and I was just kind of during my lunch
break I was scrolling through Facebook
and the Rachel Cruz show came up and I
was just kind of listening to her and
then uh she had Chris Hogan on and they
talked about uh the to the third job for
being millionaires as a teacher and I
and I was always a person that I was
like oh well I'm just never going to
make it or I'm just going to always uh
be broke cuz I'm a teacher and so when I
heard that I was like okay I I I'll I'll
bite like let's hear about this and then
that's when I started listening to your
show more and I I got hooked immediately
and then I kept trying to convince her
and she was not really having it yes I
was like a
budget what and then after a while you
know we started talking about our dreams
and things like that I was like okay
okay I'll buy it so okay and then right
after that we uh we I I finally
convinced her to let me uh buy FPU uhhuh
and then she decided to go on a spending
spree that weekend yes of course yeah
that's well you got to eat chocolate
cake when you start your diet yes okay
all right so but we we ended up binging
basically all nine episodes in probably
about four or five days okay so we like
we didn't have a a group to really get
plugged into so we just started
listening and I mean after the first
lesson she was hooked and we were like
all right let's go oh wow so once you're
on you're on yes okay all right and then
we you two teachers sers you plow your
way through 129,000 bucks uh well she
actually wasn't a teacher at first okay
she uh I was actually um wanting that we
had moved up to Houston so that I could
go to optometry school after we both
graduated from college and then I
changed my mind during
covid because I was also um working um
for an optometrist and shadowing him and
I realized that um you know my passion
is to help people and to serve people
and I felt that I could still do that
through teaching so that's why I changed
my mind and we plowed through that and
um getting my teacher HT and I started
just focusing and um teaching kids and
we started focusing on that Deb and we
ended up taking up extra jobs on the
weekends and everything so our shirts
yeah we we worked at uh Gateway Church
we worked in the children's ministry so
yeah okay yes Pastor Morris is a good
friend of mine yes they're good people
way to go guys good for you guys I'm
proud of you so what was the hardest
thing you guys fought about over almost
five
years uh what I mean there was M she
looked at you like she knows exactly the
answer and you are looking like we we
never fought everything was
great um you go okay for me it was
having to stick to the budget was the
hardest thing for me and I felt like I
was always trying
to push push it push the nodule on
trying to spend and trying to be
socially acceptable all the time and
feeling that I always can not be
empty-handed cuz that's the way I was I
grew up you know if you you know show up
to family get togethers or birthdays or
even you know if you're at your job and
they have like a party and you have to
bring something and I always felt that
pressure of we have to spend so that we
can keep up with
everyone and I realized that I had to
just stop caring about that so much and
focusing on our Dream together and being
out of debt that's powerful how has your
marriage changed over the five years of
working through this uh well we actually
uh starting off our debt free journey
within the first 3 months we were
actually on the rocks and so we actually
went through marriage counseling like
almost immediately after we started FPU
wow and uh like about two months after
we started marriage counseling I
actually lost my job and so just to make
ends meet I ended up getting a job uh as
an assistant manager at McDonald's uh
this is when we were living in Bowmont M
and so uh I mean ever since then though
I mean like our communication has gotten
better money I don't feel like ever was
like the biggest fight it was always
just something lingering it was always
usually just kind of communication
errors yeah and then uh it we had
arguments about cars too cuz you'll like
this one so uh throughout our entire
debt-free Journey we went through 10
Vehicles good Lord nine of them were in
the first two years
yes yeah we we had driving junkers or
throwaways or so we in uh starting off
we had a uh 2015 Chevy Cruise and 2004
Mitsubishi Lancer mhm
uh both a piece of junk yes so uh the
the Chevy Cruz uh we had was the one we
had a loan on so after I lost my job we
sold it and then we ended up getting a
99 Toyota Camry that's better a boy and
so when we moved to uh Houston I
actually uh wrecked the Mitsubishi
Lancer uhhuh and uh yeah wow you are not
coming out the hero in any of this oh it
gets better it gets better so then uh we
ended up getting a 97 Toyota 4Runner and
so bad yeah so then the 99 Camry uh the
Tom belt breaks while I'm driving up the
freeway in Houston so my dad ended up
helping us out giving us a 2000 Toyota
Camry that's better and while she was
driving it uh right after a Melda hit
the wheel popped off the axle oh my gosh
yes so my dad felt bad he gave and then
so he brought us a he almost killed his
daughter-in-law yes how fast were you
going uh the speed limit in Houston
you're not tell the truth cu nobody
drives speed Li in Houston well it was a
back road so okay I had to be careful
I'm not used to being on back roads all
the time so and because the thing was is
like she was driving to Bowmont from
Houston which is about an hour and a
half to 2 hour drive cuz that's where
her job was hard to do it on three
wheels and then uh we were living on the
north side of Houston I was actually
working on the south side which John as
you know Houston is an hour away from
Houston that's right so I was actually
getting up at 4:00 a.m. in the morning
in the middle of all this bull crap how
many times did you almost quit getting
out of
debt uh too too many times to to really
count what caused you to stick with it
that's amazing I'm impressed um for I it
was just having those dream talks and
rewatching the it's worth the trouble
it's worth the trouble now that you're
there and you look back on all that
stupid car I mean that that's like a
book you ought to write a book on bad
cars the bad car experience uh was it
worth it yes
100% I wouldn't trade it for anything I
would do it all again you need to ride
all those cars down in detail so you can
tell your grandkids cuz you'll forget
them I've had to go back and figure out
what cars I've owned over the years and
I didn't go through 10 and 10 months oh
my
God that's incredible way to go you guys
I'm so proud of you because the
perseverance that you built and the
Locking arms even though you hated it
every moment of it and at times didn't
like each other while you're doing it
you still that what the calluses that
you built you're going to be able to do
anything you want to do with your life
yes I'm so proud of you so very cool all
right count it down guys 129,000 paid
off in 57 months making 65 to 110 let's
hear a debt free scream ready 3 2 1 we
[Applause]
de yeah
yeah
[Music]
that's how that works this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
our scripture of today Proverbs 16:28 a
troublemaker plants seeds of strife
gossip separates the best of
friends Thomas soell says you can't stop
people from saying bad things about you
all you can do is make them
Liars that's fantastic that's pretty
good all right Patrick's with us in
Nashville hey Patrick welcome to the
Ramsey
Show uh hey do hey Dave hey John it's
good to be talking to you'all you too
man how can we
help yeah uh first of all and I'll be
quick first of all just wanted to say
thank you for the work that you all do
you and your entire team um I'm on baby
step number two still so very early on
in the process but I can already tell
you what education you put out and the
things that I've learned from you all
have changed my financial future and
honestly even more than that my kids and
maybe children's Children's financial
future so thank you well thank you
Patrick we're proud of you how can we
help yeah uh so I guess my question uh
ultimately Falls around manual
underwriting I want to give a little
context I work in higher education so Dr
John knows my world very much um
essentially my question is regarding a
potential job opportunity
uh there's a position that I've been
asked to apply for I am applying for it
uh that essentially will give me free
housing um U meal STP in phone bill paid
for so cover a lot of my Essential
expenses and essentially I'm wondering
what that looks like with if I do go
through this entire process become debt
free no credit score uh figure out if
that affects any way negatively manual
underwriting I did the exact thing I
lived on campus I I had all my bills
taken care of it affects nothing it's
all good yeah take advantage of that
glitch in The Matrix and pay off
everything you own put tons of money
away and um yeah manual underwriting
does not require a
rental for it to be approved uh a rental
background now it it
um if you have pay you know if you've
paid rent they're going to want to see
that but but in this case you're not so
for instance another place you would
have this happen is if you were in the
military and you're using you're using
base housing okay that wouldn't count
against you it's just becomes part of
your compensation at your job is what it
amounts to so it's very explainable
because the essence of manual
underwriting is is that instead of
looking at a number that says you that
you can pay your bills they're actually
looking at your
life okay can you pay your bills and
manual means a human being being is
making a value wisdom judgment on behalf
of the mortgage company and saying okay
I've got this piece of information that
says he can pay his bills I've got this
piece of information that says he can
pay his bills I've got this piece of
information that says he can pay his
bills and that's what they're looking
for when I was a a pup at 18 or 20 years
old in the 70s and 80s selling real
estate we would take there was no FICO
score we would put a house under
contract with someone and we would take
them over to the Savings and Loan the
bank and they would sit down and say all
right sign this it's a verification of
deposit and they would mail it to the
bank to verify that you had a deposit
sign this it's a VOE a verification of
employment they would mail it to your
employer to verify your income and that
you had a job sign this it's a
verification of that and they would
gather these data points and then they
would look at them and go this guy can
pay his bills
there was not any
shocking uh Revelation out of a magic
number that somehow falsely said you
were
eligible and so that's what's going on
here that's the essence of the idea of
manual underwriting and that'll put you
right where you want to be I'm proud of
you Patrick go take your job man that's
great yeah go get it get it that job
changed my family's life so go get it
where were you I was in Texas and I was
over I would have been his boss and I
had an empty apartment and this is when
my wife and I decided hey if we sold our
house and we moved in this house we
could pay off everything we own in the
next so we paid off a jillion dollar oh
so you sold your house and moved into
the moved into an apartment and that was
provided that was provided and it had
all the bills and then Hank had 175
college students as his as his roommates
in the building we lived in and ended up
being a pretty magic year for us wow
yeah very interesting but it it
transformed their lives Denise is with
us in Houston Texas hi Denise welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi John thank you guys so much
for taking my call it's my birthday
today so I'm definitely happy to happy
birthday oh thank you so much um my
question is I am wondering if I should
or how I can get out of U my car
situation I currently have a 2020
kiaforte uh negative equity in it
unfortunately I purchased it last year
and I just feel like it's draining the
ability for me to be able to make um
have higher savings and just kind of get
get to a better place really know uh
22,000 okay what do you
make 57,000 M and uh what's your car
payment car payment is 460 okay and um
so what do you think it's
worth uh from KBB I looked up it's worth
about 14 Grand 13 or 14 Grand that's
trade
in no she rolled in negative Equity oh
you rolled in negative
equity correct oh I missed that part oh
jeez okay so the is that private sale
you owe
14 uh yes private sale or it's worth 14
I'm sorry ah so you're eight in the hole
I would owe a roughly 8K yeah
yeah and I thought maybe you know pretty
soon I could start trying to double up
on payment and get out of my um um my
balance sooner my how much other Deb do
you
have 6K in student loans 2,100 and a
credit card that's it okay no I'm just
going to I'm just going to work your
debt snowball pay your minimum payments
and and pay everything you can on your
smallest debt and then when that was
gone pay everything you can on your next
smallest debt that's $10,000 clear that
um and then when you don't have those
two payments anymore then we're going to
tear into this car and we're going to
pay not double payments but triple
quadruple payments or whatever you know
pay $33,000 a month on it I don't care
and let's just get it paid down because
it's the car is not the problem the car
before this car is the
problem and so you're not solving the
math problem when you go from 22 to 8 if
you go from 22 to two you'd be solving
the math problem
right right but you're not you don't
make enough Headway here by getting rid
of this by sacrificing this car in this
case what I would do is just tear into
it with a v
and say okay I've got um you know
$32,000 worth of debt I make 57 I'm
going to work six jobs do nothing go not
go out to eat I'm going to pour
everything I can get my hands on onto
this 50 I mean onto this $322,000 worth
of debt and in 18 to 24 months I'm going
to be 100% debt-free car and everything
and then if you want to sell the car
sell it but get it paid
off perfect that's kind of what I was
thinking thank you guys so much yeah you
have you been through Financial Peace
University yet
Marie uh Denise I have not no I'm sorry
Denise I'm I'm looking at theen I
younger I did my family like how old are
you when I was I'm 29 today that's Happy
Birthday hey we're going to give you a
birthday gift and a Christmas gift I
want you to go through Financial Peace
University as my
guest okay thank you so much yeah I want
you to go do that stuff cuz I I can hear
it in the way you're looking at this
you're you're the way you're forming
your language you're actually going to
do
it you're you're going to do this yeah I
am I'm very passionate and yes I
definitely want to knock it out Denise
can I ask you a quick
question yes sir how many years in a row
have you been
29 zero all
right a real 29 well
done it's the 33rd anniversary of my
29th 2th birthday
oh my gosh oh happy birthday Denise hang
on Austin will pick up and we'll get you
signed up for Financial Peace University
as our guest uh we got about 10 we just
passed 10,000 classes that were taught
this year wow I just did a little video
thanking all the coordinators before we
got on the air 10,000 classes 10,000
classes were taught this year and uh it
it gets away the numbers are are
astronomical I mean that's it's a lot of
people yeah and um we're starting to add
up now how much um charity has been
given by all these people and it's it's
uh astronomical how much of the economy
you can affect by doing something like
this that puts us hour the ramsy show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
a